$1.75 GAS AFTER REBATE.
A REBATE WILL LEGALLY
ALLOW DANIEL
TO ADVERTISE THE CHEAPEST GAS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND BECAUSE
IT'S SUCH A GREAT DEAL,
IT WOULD ONLY BE FAIR
TO MAKE CLAIMING THIS REBATE
A BIT MORE INCONVENIENT
THAN NORMAL,
BY ASKING CUSTOMERS
TO DROP IT OFF IN PERSON
AT THE TOP OF A MOUNTAIN.
- AT THE TOP
OF THE MOUNTAIN.
YEAH, THAT'S GOOD TRICKY WAY
TO MAKE MONEY.
- ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF
DRIVE FROM SEVAN GAS
IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ANGELES NATIONAL FOREST,
THE PEAK OF MOUNT CHILEO
IS ONLY ACCESSIBLE BY FOOT.
I EXPLAINED TO DANIEL
THAT AS LONG AS HE WAS UP FRONT
WITH HIS CUSTOMERS,
PUTTING THE REBATE BOX
ATOP CHILEO
WAS COMPLETELY 100% LEGAL.
- IF SOME OF THEM
IS GONNA CLAIM IT,
IT'S GONNA COST ME MONEY,
RIGHT?
- DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
ARE GONNA HIKE UP A MOUNTAIN
TO GET THIS REBATE?
- UH...
- AFTER A WEEK
TO GET EVERYTHING PREPARED,
WE IMPLEMENTED THE OFFER.
WITHIN MINUTES
OF THE SIGN GOING UP,
IT PROVED TO BE
AN INSTANT HIT,
WITH A LINE OF CARS
DOWN THE BLOCK.
- IS IT REALLY $1.75?
- AFTER REBATE.
- WHAT TYPE OF REBATE?
- IT'S NOT MAIL-IN REBATE.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT
PERSONALLY.
- WHERE'S IT AT?
- MOUNTAIN CHILE.
- WHERE?